is TI's prize pool going to be the
lowest it's ever been as many of you
know dota's the international always and
I mean always has the biggest prize
pools we're talking in the millions of
millions kind of money for contacts it
has eight of the 11 biggest priz pools
in eorts history so not only do teams
get the glory of lifting the Aegis they
get generational wealth too but this
year might be a little different
according to the Dota 2 prize pool
tracker TI 2023 isn't even close to
being on Pace but why well this year Val
changed the compendium so that it
focuses Less on in-game cosmetics and
more on the Esports scene itself which
people did not like yeah no thanks valve
is also taking a bigger cut from the
earnings so bada bing bada boom less
money that being said it's still almost
three fing
million